>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Paulette Hasier:
Good afternoon everyone.
Thank you for coming to the
Phillip Lee Phillips lecture
that we're having today
on World War I.
My name is Paulette Hasier.
I am the Chief of the
Geography and Map Division going
on four months at the
end of this week.
So, I'm very pleased to introduce
our moderator for the event,
and that will be Mr. Dick
Pflederer and he will come up.
Thank you again.
[ Applause ]
>> Richard Pflederer: We
appreciate that invitation,
and also the reference
to the Phillips Society.
I'm curious to know
if we have any members
of the Phillips Society
present here.
Raise your hand please?
Wow, good.
Well, before we get into
actually discussing the program,
I wanted to take just a minute
to talk about the society.
If you signed it outside and
you're not a member already,
you may get an email because we
are always looking for members.
A brief history: The
society has been
in action for more than 20 years.
Our goal is to support the G
and M Division of the library,
both financially and with
programs such as this.
And we hope that you will
take a minute to look
at the materials we have outside.
I'm just going to hold up one card
which is of particular interest
to me because that's the one
you get to put an envelope
with your check if
you want to do that.
I'll also tell you
that that is optional.
That is not a requirement of
membership to make a donation.
But we want to see as many
people at these lectures.
We want to see as many people
utilizing the facilities.
Okay, with that behind us, I want
to talk about today's program.
And we're really lucky
for a couple of reasons,
mostly that we have
two great speakers.
Before I introduce the speakers,
I wanted to just give a word
about the subject, World War I.
You may know that the
US officially entered
that war 100 years ago last month,
so we're looking at an event
that is, for us who are
maybe a little bit older,
it's not so long ago, but for the
young people it's something like --
It's like the Civil War
was when I was a kid,
as far as that far
distance in the past.
You probably know that we had the
so-called American Expeditionary
Force under the leadership
of General John Pershing.
And it took us a while to get,
let's say, fully mobilized.
In fact, it's about a year before
we actually achieved a headcount
on the ground in Europe
of 1 million people.
But by November 1918, when the war
ended of course, we were pouring,
literally pouring resources
into that Western front,
10,000 new American faces
every day are on the ground.
So, you know, we're going to hear
a speaker later who was British
and we can't even measure the impact
that that war and the sacrifices
that they made had on Britain.
And of course, France
was probably even worse.
So, I promise to keep
the so-called overhead
of today's session
as short as I could.
And I wanted to start by introducing
our first speaker, Mr. Ryan Moore,
who is a member of the staff
of the G and M Division,
and I want to give a little
bit of background about him.
He's quite active as an author.
In fact, there's also a copy of an
occasional paper that he's authored,
which is out there which
is available, I guess,
for anyone who doesn't have
it who wants to take it.
But Ryan's education
is quite interesting.
He has an undergraduate degree
from Cleveland State University
and he has two advanced degrees, one
from Kent State in Library Science
and the other from Cleveland
State University in History.
Before coming to the
Library of Congress,
he had worked for four years
in the Special Collections
of the Cleveland Public Library,
which is quite a substantial
library,
and he's been in the
Library of Congress here
for just about 10 years now.
His subject is the maps of World War
I, and he's going to look at the way
that maps illustrated
the military, yes,
but also the political
facets of the war.
He's also going to discuss
aerial photography, the scouting,
and also an interesting
sideline I hadn't thought of,
and that is how did the
interviews of prisoners --
German prisoners in this case --
affect the content, the detail,
that was on the US
maps of that period.
So, without any further ado,
we will ask Ryan to come
up here and give his talk.
[ Applause ]
>> Ryan Moore: Thank you very
much for the introduction.
And before I begin,
I've always reminded
to say please and thank you.
I think it's the appropriate
thing to always begin with please
and end with a thank you.
And so, I'm pleased
to thank all of you.
I want to start by thanking
Dr. Abear who is here.
When I first came to G and M,
encourage me to go
beyond my interest
in World War II, and
look at World War I.
And his advice was
just to the point.
He said, "That World War
II field is too crowded.
Look at something else."
And he was right.
It's a great field of
study and it's something
that I am very interested in,
but broadening one's horizons
with these great collections
that we have here
at the library has been a
wonderful experience for me.
Ralph Ehrenberg, who is also here --
When I worked under him when he was
Chief of Division when he returned,
we worked together on
the Phillips Society
in reenergizing the occasional
papers and getting people to start
to actively write about
our collections
and promote them through
that research.
It was a great time to work
with him and a pleasure
to be part of that process.
And now we have Chief
Hasier who was with us.
She comes from a background NGA,
National Geo Special Intelligence
Agency, and she's bringing new ideas
about technology, and it's an
exciting time to be in the division.
I'm glad that all three of these
Chiefs can be here at one time.
It's a great day.
So at that being said, I
would like to begin my talk.
The Library of Congress
intersected with World War I
with the publication of A List
of Atlases and Maps Applicable
to World War I (1918) authored
by Phillip Lee Phillips,
the namesake of our organization.
Phillips was the first
superintendent of maps
at the Library of Congress.
He compiled a list of maps
-- political maps, road maps,
railroad maps were printed
contemporaneous to this event.
So, these were ways that
people could find information
about what countries looked
like, what the situation
on the ground may be, because what
media was available at that time?
Photographs, maps, the written word.
There was not video, instant video,
Twitter feeds today
that would inform us.
So, this resource was very valuable
for not only the common
researcher but for policymakers.
What I plan to talk about today,
as Mr. Pflederer mentioned,
is I'm going to mention maps that
illustrate the history of the war.
So, the storytelling piece.
When the general public wanted
to know what was going on,
how is this information
conveyed to them?
A second part of my discussion
will entail an overview
of the relationship between
maps, intelligence gathering,
primarily photographs but
also prisoners' statements,
and how that affected the use
of weapons, primarily artillery.
And lastly, I'm going to
close was showing some maps
that describe the process of peace
and how that was related to Germany
and how that sort of was
an omen for the next war.
So, you're all probably familiar
with this story, this estimation
of Franz Ferdinand and his
wife Sophia by Gavrilo Princip,
down there in the lower corner.
They were visiting Sarajevo
and he was essentially there
to review the maneuvers
of some troops,
and he had taken a
tour through the city.
Princip and his associates were
funded and supplied with weapons
by a group called the Black Hand.
They had a relationship
with Serbian intelligence
and possibly higher elements
in the Serbian government.
It's still in dispute today
how high up that may have gone.
But nonetheless, they were
given weapons and transported
into Bosnia-Herzegovina,
which was occupied
by the Austro-Hungarian Empire.
Princip and his associates lined
this road here along the [Inaudible]
River, waiting for Ferdinand's
possession to come by.
They fanned out along the road
with the idea being that, "Well,
if you don't have a good
shot at him, let him go by.
The next person will
take a shot at him."
So what happens is the
entourage passes and one
of the assassins throws
a bomb out onto the road.
It doesn't land under
the Archduke's car,
but one of his secretary's cars,
and those folks are
injured by the blast.
The Archduke goes to the town hall
and protests about the situation.
He is advised to leave because
they say, "Well obviously,
there was an attempt on your life.
You should get out of
here as soon as possible.
We can't ensure your security."
Well, before leaving they want
to check on the injured parties
and then depart from the city.
Princip, while this is happening,
he's 19 and 20, it depends.
There was a dispute about
his age as well at the time.
And he is dejected because
he is a very ardent Bosnian
Serb nationalist.
He wants to see the Archduke killed.
The reason being is that this
guy has some liberalizing ideas
about the Empire.
They want to give their
constituent groups more autonomy.
His group feels, "Well, if you
give Bosnian Serbs more autonomy
that may steal the thunder
of the Pan-Serbian movement,
and we want people
radicalized, not pacified."
So he's sitting in a
café feeling dejected.
And then what happens is they
come back down from the City Hall
to this area here where
this arrow is.
The driver makes a wrong turn.
Princip can't believe his eyes.
There's the Archduke sitting in a
car several feet in front of him.
He immediately gets up, pulls
a pistol out of his jacket,
walks up to the side rail and fires,
and hits the Archduke
and his wife Sophia.
The Archduke implores
his wife, "Sophia,
please live for the children."
They have several children together.
Princip, he is supposed
to commit suicide.
All the assassins actually
are supposed to commit suicide
after they make an attempt.
He has been given a cyanide pill
which he takes and it doesn't work.
He attempts to put
the gun to his head,
and security wrestles
it from his hand.
He will wind up in Austrian
prison and died in 1916.
He has tuberculosis at the time
that he commits this assassination.
He will languish in a
prison cell and die.
So the question always is, how do we
go from this event to a world war?
And the stars like Margaret
McMillan, for example,
The Road to War, discusses
at length.
And I encourage anyone
who is very curious
about all the particular political
details that go into the making
of the First World War to
dig into books such as that.
So at the outset of the conflict,
we have a couple of countries lining
up together because they
have diplomatic agreements.
The countries in pink --
France, Russia, and England,
although England is a
slight technicality here
which I'll mention -- is that they
agreed to a mutual defense pact.
England has agreed in principle,
and their militaries
have discussed plans
of mutual defense should
it be necessary,
but they are not a signatory
towards any defense pact.
Germany, Austria-Hungary, and Italy
also have a mutual defense pact.
What the Austro-Hungarians wanted
to do is they want to invade Serbia.
Well, Russia says, "If
you invade Serbia --
" And they consider
Serbia, it's been said,
is the little brother of Russia.
It's not a pejorative term.
It's sort of a very familial
term in that part of the world.
They said, "If you attack
here, we'll attack here."
The Austro-Hungarians then
turned to the Germans for help.
They said, "We can't defend the
Russians and attack Serbia at once.
We don't have enough troops."
So, this is where our complication
begins, with the Germans,
and this is how we get a world war.
And I'm going to skip forward
and explain that and come back
to all the belligerents in a second.
There's something called
the von Schlieffen plan.
The Germans said, "Our big
enemies are France and Russia."
Now, if Russia mobilizes
against Austria-Hungary
over this Serbia issue, that
means France will mobilize too.
If they mobilize their troops first,
they have a distinct
advantage of us if we wait.
So we must mobilize.
But the problem with mobilization in
Germany is this von Schlieffen plan.
It's been kept a secret since
1905, when it was first conceived
and later revised through the years.
And what it said was Germany
has to strike first to win.
We're fighting two major
powers, France and Russia.
What we want to do is hold the
Russians at bay with a small amount
of forces as possible, put the
bulk of our forces against France
and to march through
Belgium and to take Paris
and knock the French out of the war.
In six weeks this has to be done.
And this is a time when soldiers
primarily move my walking, okay.
So they're going to have
to march 20 miles a day
to make this happen, if not more.
So they tell the Kaiser, they
said, "Russia is angling for war.
We have to mobilize.
And by the way, if we mobilize,
we must fight because that
reveals a secret plan.
Because we move troops to the front,
they know what our intentions are.
We have to fight."
So to go back here for a second, so
that will expand the war eventually.
By 1917, the United
States will enter the war,
and we see our former
President Wilson here.
And this map was one of the many
educational maps that were printed
at the time to inform the
public what was going on.
It compares the area of Europe here
inside the continental United States
to sort of explain to the
everyday American how big
and powerful our country
is, it's suggesting,
and all these countries
fit within our borders.
It's telling who are
the Allies, America,
and a lot of people
are surprised to learn
that the Japanese Empire
was an ally,
a very important ally
in World War I.
They, in fact, were responsible
for patrolling the Pacific
and protecting commercial and troop
transports moving from Australia,
New Zealand, and India
to the Western front.
The British had stripped most of
their ships as well as the French
to affect the blockade
against the Germans.
So the Japanese were a very key
ally in the First World War,
as was Italy, Great Britain, France
who bore the bulk of the fighting
and suffered the highest level
of casualties, and of course,
Great Britain and Canada.
And there were other minor countries
supporting the war effort as well.
The Central Powers were
not as international.
These countries were Germany,
Austria-Hungary, Bulgaria,
and the Ottoman Empire --
these countries in black.
These individuals over
here, the Kaiser of Germany,
the Kaiser of Austria-Hungary,
the Sultan of the Ottoman Empire,
and the Czar of Bulgaria.
They believed that their
location in proximity
to one another would allow them to
have a strong common core defense,
and could move troops wherever
they needed them by rail --
which I'm going to discuss
next -- to fight the Allies.
They were able to mobilize 22.8
million military personnel,
and if I can jump back and show you
that the Allies were much stronger,
42.2 million military personnel.
In addition to people
who are fighting,
the Allies though also were
materially richer, bigger factories,
more natural resources,
greater shipping industry
to move the stuff around.
So, it was important for the Central
Powers then got to get involved
in a long protracted war because
they did not have the resources
to contend with such might.
So the Germans -- going back
to the von Schlieffen plan --
had a strategic rail network in
the country, and this allowed them
to rapidly move forces from
here, the Eastern front
of the Western front and vice versa.
German staff officers were charged
with plotting how long it would take
for a given troop unit to move
from one front to another,
and they would practice these
and memorize these schedules,
because timing was very important,
the delivery of the troops
to the front had to be
done at a precise time.
Once the von Schlieffen
plan was given the go-ahead,
they couldn't have some
troops there ready to go,
waiting around for others.
They had to all be in place.
And the Germans built these
mile-long rail platforms
so they could take troops on and off
the trains as rapidly as possible.
And when these things were going
up, the Belgians in particular
on the border noticed this.
Like their intelligence
service said, "Hey,
we're spotting these mile-long
rail platforms and these sort
of country towns on the border.
What's going on?
Either big real estate investment
in the future or it smells
like a possible war is brewing."
And they were very
concerned about that.
So, my me to use a pictorial
map to sort of explain
to you the opening
phases of the war.
This comes from a French
publication,
and we see Falkenhayn giving
the uppercut to Joffre.
And the Germans were initially
very successful in marching
through Belgium and
portions of France.
The Belgians, although they
were a neutral country,
they were very powerful, and
they punched above their weight
because they had vast resources
coming in from the Congo.
And if you ever heard of the
novel, "The Heart of Darkness,"
it was about the Belgian Congo.
And King Leopold II had a secret
private empire in the Congo
where he became very
personally wealthy,
and the entire country
Belgium became very wealthy.
And so therefore, with this money
they were able to erect a series
of fortifications along
the border with Germany
that they thought would stop
any kind of invasion attempt.
The problem was, the Germans
invented these massive railroad guns
that they would train in on
the fort and just blast it.
So once you build a fort,
the problem with the
fort is it can't move.
Patton said it's a monument
to the stupidity of mankind.
Because once the enemy locates
the fort, surrounds the fort,
unless you can come to the aid of
a fort, it will be lost eventually.
So the Germans were able
to smash through Belgium.
And as they moved within
reach of Paris,
the Allies rallied their forces.
At the First Battle of the Marne,
they found that the Germans
had exposed their flank,
and they took advantage of
this gap in the German armies,
and they temporarily
checked the German advance.
There German said, "Okay,
we're going to go around this,
and started something called
"the race to the sea."
They weren't literally running
to the sea, but they were trying
to outflank another, the
Germans and the Allies.
And they went all the way
up to the Belgian coast.
And it culminated with
the Battle of Ypres,
where the Allies were again
able to check the Germans.
And at this time, the war is
very fluid, it's very mobile.
We think trenches, World War I.
At this time, it's
not trench warfare.
They're fighting in open country.
They're trying to get around one
another and secure the best ground.
And the Germans don't want to erect
any kind of temporary fortification
because they want Paris,
they want to knock it out.
And they get their troops
over to the Eastern front
to fight the Russians
who are mobilizing.
So the question in Germany became,
in 1915 after all those
opening moves, what's going on?
Where does our Army stand in France?
This is a commercial map
published by Dietrich Reimer,
a very famous German
publishing house.
Probably, you could say,
it's akin to a Rand McNally,
that kind of level of popularity.
And they regularly published maps
to show the situation on the ground.
And these theater maps were
very popular in Germany,
and other countries had
similar kind of mapping
that was also very popular.
What I've done here is I pulled
this out over here for everyone,
and I have annotated it here.
This is the blue showing
the German main movements
through Belgium towards Paris,
and also making a side
thrust here into France.
These areas in red were
fortifications or major cities
that they had to go
through or bypass.
So what happens is that the front
starts to settle in 1915, in 1916.
And the geography of this land
in France here is that it's sort
of gently rolling up this way.
And the Germans are in a naturally
elevated place over the Allies,
and they decide that
they're going to dig in here
because the Russians have
entered the war and they need
to send some troops
back to do with that.
So they start to do trench lines
all the way down to Switzerland,
and the Allies will respond
with their own countering set
of trench lines along the way.
The British were concerned what
the Americans were thinking,
because they viewed us as a
potential ally to help deal
with this crisis on
the Western front.
One means to educate Americans,
and you could put that in quotes --
you know, you could use the word
"propaganda" -- was to use a map.
This map is by a publishing house
called Stanford's of London,
and it's showing the battlefronts
of Europe and comparing it
with traveling time that
Americans could think,
"Oh yeah, that makes sense to me.
If the Western front is some 450
miles long, that's half the distance
from New York to Chicago."
So these kinds of maps helped an
American audience digest not only
what was going on, but
sort of a geographic scale
on which the fighting was occurring.
And it's interesting
what the map says here.
Some of this language
I know you can't see,
but I want to share it with you.
This is on the eve of America
sending its troops into Europe.
The US has decided to go to war,
and the British mapmaker says this.
It says. "Despite the victories
which have crowned the Allied arms,
their task still remains a heavy
one, and it will need every effort
which they and their American
comrades can put into the struggle
to defeat the sinister aims
of Prussian militarism."
And we will revisit this term
"Prussian militarism"
at the end of the talk.
But what it alludes to is
before Germany was a country,
there was a very large
state called Prussia.
Frederick the Great, you
may have heard the name --
They were kind of like a
European ancient Sparta.
They were a military state.
It's been said that, you know,
some countries have an army.
Well, this army has a country.
And that sort of belief was carried
on into German culture
at the time here.
So now, let's have an
overview of military maps.
What they did -- how they
were using the result of them.
I call this a military
mapping revolution.
What do I mean by that?
Well, never before was information
about the field of battle,
its scope, the particular details
of the train, the obstacles
and the enemy formations given to a
junior officer in a map form before.
In World War I, millions
of maps were produced.
The U.S. Army alone produced 3.5
million maps for its own forces,
and it was just there from
1917 until November 11, 1918.
Maps were made every day of the war,
often updated every day of the war,
a very detailed level
of intelligence.
So, we're going to talk about,
what were they looking for?
They were looking for the enemy's
artillery, their trench lines,
obstacles, routes in and out,
and something called
"the order of battle."
That means, who are the enemy
troops, how strong are they,
how long have they
been in the battle,
and what's the overall situation?
How is that information gathered?
Through reconnaissance,
direct observation by people
on the ground, and
aerial photographs.
Prisoners, of course, were an
important source of information.
Sometimes they willingly gave it
over for a sandwich and a cigar.
Defectors and spies.
And the result of all this was
that tremendous tactical mapping
at a very scale, high level
of detail, and it allowed
for massive deployments
of troops and bombardments
that were beyond what
the eye could see.
As you know in historic battles,
such as the Revolutionary War,
the Civil War, the Napoleonic
War, the general himself would get
on a horse and serve
at the battlefield,
and be able to see everything.
Well, these battles are stretching
for miles and miles and miles.
One general cannot
see what's going on.
He needs a map.
And then, for the subordinates
in the field to understand
and to translate his orders into
action, they need a map that relates
to their particular situation.
And this resulted in some
of the deadliest battles
in the history of warfare.
When the war began,
however, in 1914,
they were making all these
great big strategic plans
like the von Schlieffen plan.
The other countries had their
plans and they were wrapping
up their militaries with
the latest weaponry.
But the mapping effort was
not on par with that energy.
When both sides went to war,
they were relying on maps
that were printed in the 1880s
that were these large-scale maps.
And when I talk about map scale,
think of it like this
-- one to one is unity.
It's the same.
And the more you move away from
that, you're able to show more
of the earth, but in less detail.
So this is showing
1 to 8000 in France.
And this is a great regional
picture, but if you are asked
to go take the enemy dug out, well,
where's even the trench
line on this map?
It would be so small.
It's useless for a tactical purpose.
So it took them two
years to get things right
on both sides on the Western front.
They developed things
called tactical maps,
which I've talked about.
So for the infantry, the
guy fighting on the ground,
he wants a map at 1 to 10,000.
This is going to show you
buildings, trees in some cases
with the Germans map,
particular trees, wells,
very detailed information.
The artillery want a little
bit of a bigger picture
because they're shooting
miles down the road.
And for planning, 1 to 40,000,
I'd give me a regional picture
and then I'll translate that
information into the infantry
and the artillery planning.
It has to show topography.
It has to show waterways,
roads, communication lines,
of course buildings and
military information.
And things, although we think,
"Oh, it's a static war --
they're in trenches,"
what was going on in
and around those trenches
was changing all the time.
And so, that information needed
to be updated daily often.
Even if nothing changed, that might
be a sign of something is going on.
Why is nothing going
on on the German side?
We don't see anything.
Well, maybe they've taken some
guys across the way and moved them
down the line because they
want to attack down the line.
So that information
is also important.
So here's a blowup of
that same tactical map,
and it's a German map, by the way.
And it's showing an
Allied trench line.
They don't put their own
information on this map
because this is given
to a junior officer.
And if he's out in the field and
he's captured or he drops this
and they show their own trench line,
that's given away intelligence
to the enemy.
So often, what the folks in the
field had was a one-sided depiction.
So, we see here an Allied trench
line with these X's are here
in red that I'm tracing along.
That's barbed wire,
and there are many,
many rows of barbed
wire to inhibit attack.
You can't pass through barbed
wire unless you blast it
with artillery -- it's
that thick and dense.
Over here, we have a legend that
explains the information on the map.
So the Germans even
went down to the level
of showing deciduous
verses evergreen trees.
I mean, they plotted this stuff.
It's amazing.
I suppose -- we were joking
about that earlier, Peter and I.
But I guess that matters if
you're operating in a time
when there's leaves on
the tree verses not.
Are your troops concealed
or are they not concealed?
Town maps -- how to interpret that.
How to interpret topography and
various structures on a map,
because junior officers are
not necessarily map experts.
You've got to lay this out in
a very literal and clear way
so that somebody with a low level
of training can use it effectively.
So maps, as we know,
operate with a grid.
You see that on all these maps,
every sort of maybe not think
about the intended purpose.
So it's about subdividing geographic
space and allowing one to point
to a specific place on earth
and share that information
in common with someone else.
You don't want to say, "Dr.
Abear, take the platoon
down the road and take the church."
"What church are you
asking me to take?"
Right? If I give you a set
of coordinates then we can agree
upon where is it going to be.
And so, the way these grids
worked is that there was one
for the 40,000, which was used
for planning, and one of 10,000.
And each one of these squares would
get divided into four sectors,
and that it would get
sub-divided again into 10,
so these are 50 yard squares here.
So it allows immense precision when
talking about a geographic location
that should be bombarded
or should be attacked.
And the same holds true
for aerial photography.
It operated on a grid system
and they were given the job
of mapping a particular
lettered square.
This map here is by the British.
It's in Belgium, of Ypres.
And I'm going to show
you, they were challenged
with mapping letter I -- right here.
As you can see on the map here
showing the town in the river,
and here is the aerial
photograph of this location.
Amazingly accurate, right?
And we're talking, this
is 1916-1917 flyover.
And to make this happen, they
would go into enemy territory
on a daily basis, flying at
altitudes 10,000 feet maybe,
lower sometimes, to get
this kind of clarity.
And that would put them in
range of any anti-aircraft.
It was a very dangerous
business doing this.
And they were asked to go over
every day because planners
and analysts wanted to
see if there's any change
in what you captured today,
and how can we compare
that to what's happened in the past.
So we can either have an
indication that they plan to attack
or if they want to recede
from a certain area.
They want to know that.
So, this stuff is happening
on a daily basis.
And flying in World War I, by the
way, was a very dangerous business.
Most people are killed on takeoff.
These are wooden planes, and if the
engine failed, you're in a plane
with a heavy camera and
another person who's going
to take the pictures.
And if you don't get enough
lift and you come down heavy,
that's the end, generally speaking.
So, what were they
taking photographs of?
What are you supposed to be
looking for if you're an analyst?
So I'm going to ask all of you.
Like, say you're an analyst and
this gets returned from a flight,
and they said, "Where is
the machine gun nest?"
Now, we can't ask Paulette
because she has a background
in this stuff, so she doesn't count.
But some of you, if you
were given this photograph,
where's the machine gun nest?
It's right here.
See this round secular
running in pairs?
There is two actually in this mound.
What they were taught to
look for were features
that don't generally
occur in nature.
And human beings have a tendency
to build things logically,
geometrically.
And when you look at the earth,
the earth doesn't form that way.
In the human mind, it wants to
construct it in this fashion.
So they're taught to look for
what the human would build.
And so, right there is a machine
gun that's on a hill that commands
over these trenches down here.
And there's a lot more
enemy activity actually
on this photograph.
Up here is a headquarters.
These buildings, they determined
prisoners were being kept in.
They set up roadblocks here.
So, this flyover intelligence
was very important
to develop tactical knowledge
of what the enemy was doing
and where he was situated.
So the question becomes,
okay, you got a photograph.
You know where it is.
How do you get that to a map?
There are no computers.
There's no GPS.
There is no cut and pasting.
So the process is called
rectification,
meaning transferring the information
onto a map to have it lined
up with the coordinates of the map.
It was a very primitive
process, yet very effective.
What mappers were taught
to do was find the point
that you're interested in that
shows up on a photograph here.
Alignment it with known points.
And they would trace the
photograph using tracing paper.
And then, they would take that known
grid which I told you about earlier
where the plane would fly
over, and they would layer
that upon a topographic map and
they would draw that onto the map.
And that's how intelligence would
get laid over onto existing maps.
It seems very basic and rudimentary,
but it was miles and miles ahead
with the world had ever done before
in terms of military mapping.
Now, eyes on the ground
also was still important
for intelligence mapping
in World War I.
This is a patrol map from the
Germans in the Saint-Mihiel sector
where the Americans launched
our first American-led
offensive campaign.
All sides sent patrols out, usually
at dawn or dusk to use the cover
of darkness, and to approach
-- go through no man's land --
as quietly as possible, and to
take note of the enemy lines.
What do you see?
Are they cooking food?
Do you see anything behind the
lines, like trucks or supplies
that had been recently deposited?
Do you see artillery?
When did you see?
How much did you say?
Patrol leaders in both armies
were required to fill out reports
about what they had
seen, when, and where.
This information would be then
kicked back to their headquarters
and also used to update maps.
And if they could such a patrol,
they loved to grab a prisoner.
Sometimes they grabbed a
sentry, who was unwilling.
Sometimes the guy on the other side,
you know, I mean, was giving himself
up too quickly without a fight.
And this here is an American map
that shows intelligence garnered
from a prisoner about
the German lines.
We have here showing machine guns.
Prisoner told them -- Here's
the American line, by the way.
Here's the German line, okay.
The Germans often would move
machine guns up close to the line
to harass the Americans
in their trench.
Should anyone stick their head
up, they would unload a blast
of machine-gun fire on them.
It told about a German
observation balloon here.
Although we had planes, balloons
were still very important
and very effective, but it
was a terrible job to have
because they were very visual
to the enemy and they would go
after them whenever possible.
And if you're in a balloon that
catches fire and is coming down,
there's really no way out.
Here the Germans have an airfield.
And behind, deep in their
line, is their artillery,
their heavy artillery, field
artillery, and their mortars.
So this information from
prisoners is very valuable
to get a better picture
of the enemy lines.
Aerial photography couldn't always
get the stuff because you learn
to camouflage, you learn
to adapt and overcome.
The enemy is spying from above,
so they would throw netting
or do various things to try to
deceive the aerial reconnaissance.
And we see this sort of going
on today in the various wars
in Afghanistan and elsewhere in the
Middle East, in northern Africa.
United States and NATO has drones
and airplanes, heat detection.
So, opposition elements are turning
towards tunnels, concealment.
It's a cat and mouse game from the
beginning of warfare has occurred,
and this is part of that.
All of this information
would be used to culminate
in something called "the
enemy order of battle."
What does that mean?
Ideally, you can identify
enemy units by their name.
Who are they?
What's their specialty?
What is the quality of those troops?
Do they have experience?
Are they very green?
Also equally important is how
long have they been fighting?
You know, if they're good
troops, good troops get tired.
And the Germans -- because
I mentioned earlier,
the Central Powers had less
manpower than the allies --
they could not rotate
their men off the line.
When you're on the line,
you stayed on the line.
And individuals would
maybe go on leave,
but groups of soldiers would not
be taken off the line together.
The Allies had that luxury.
They could take a whole unit off
and put a whole new unit
on the line to rest.
Also, when were they last in battle
and what's their morale
and level of supply?
If they have low morale
and they're not being fed,
maybe that's where
you want to attack,
because they're going
to maybe give up easier.
And if you can create a hole in the
enemy line with one of these units
that has low morale or low supply,
you could compromise their
entire defense in a given area.
And so, that opportunity was a kind
of opportunity the planners
would look to exploit.
And they would present this
information to commanding officers
to make decisions about operations.
The last map I'm going to mention
of the military kind
here is a planning map.
This is a map from the
Meuse-Argonne, and these kind
of maps have a particular look.
They show something called
jumping off points here,
where units would begin in a battle.
And they would follow a line
of progress, [inaudible] line.
They were given a sector.
"You stay in your lane
and I stay in my lane,
and we move forward together,
so that we don't get
salience in our line.
We don't want to have one group
go forward, and a group next
to it stays behind, because that
protruding salient then becomes
vulnerable to attack on two sides.
We want to move together along
the same axis of advance.
And so, this is the beginning
of the Meuse-Argonne offensive,
all the way up to November
11 on the armistice,
where we pushed the Germans back.
Now, I mentioned in the
beginning, weapons were important
to [inaudible], and the greatest
weapon in the most effective weapon
of the war was artillery,
responsible for some 60 plus
percent of all casualties.
These are some of the various guns
that the American army employed,
from this field artillery
here to this railgun
which could shoot some 20 miles.
And it would lay waste
to the landscape.
Forested areas would just turn
into effectively something
looking like a lunar landscape.
The amount of devastation that they
could deliver was incredible --
incredible in a very
dark way, of course.
What makes this possible are
maps to direct this fire.
They're not just guessing.
They're firing at known points.
Towards the end of the war,
the mapping was so accurate
that they felt that they could hit
something that had an air factor
of maybe 50 to 20 yards of being
off if they just used a map
with no pre-firing, where they
could see the round go down.
And the spotter would call
back and say "Adjust."
They felt that they had mapped
it effectively, they could shoot
and surprise the enemy and
not give them a chance to move
and hit the target, and
that's very incredible.
This is all analog.
There's no digital,
GPS guiding this stuff.
Yeah, it was amazing --
again, in a very dark way.
This map here comes from one
of our special collections,
the John Heinz Collection,
and it shows America's first
artillery shock of the war.
It's kind of a neat specimen
to have in our archive here.
On October 23, 1917 at
approximately 6:30 AM,
Battery C of the six field
regiment, first field brigade,
first division -- have to get it
all in -- under Colonel Scott,
Major Starkey, and Captain McLendon,
said to Sergeant Alexander
Arch, "Go ahead and shoot."
And Aches' battery is here,
and they take the first shot
against the Germans in anger.
General Pershing said,
"That's a special gun."
Pershing is the commander-in-chief
of the American forces.
He said, "Send that gun home,"
and that gun is in West Point now.
And the gun, incidentally, is French
make, 75 millimeter field gun.
The United States Army, at
the time of World War I,
did not have a lot
of heavy ordinance.
We were able to bring
bodies to Europe,
but not necessarily
the gear to go with it.
We had to use British and
French equipment to fight.
This is very different
in World War I,
where we're supplying all the
Allies with various armaments,
like the British with
Sherman tanks and the Russians
with trucks, for example.
So this is a very interesting
piece of history right here
from the Library of
Congress' collections.
One tactic that made artillery
so devastating was something
called creeping barrage,
something developed by the British
in the Boer Wars of South Africa.
Creeping barrage meant we want to
put the artillery fire in front
of our troops, and have that fire
move forward while our troops move
behind it to limit
the enemy's ability
to shoot our troops advancing.
In order to pull off this complex
maneuver, two things are important.
You got to both know
where you're going to be,
because you don't want the guys here
when the bombs are falling here.
They want to be behind
these various rings of fire,
"curtain of fire" they called it,
and what time that
that would happen.
So the artillery unit and the unit
in the field would share the same
map, and according to a schedule,
they would move together.
And this was very effective
at blasting away barbed wire
and other enemy emplacements
along the way,
to reach the final objective where
then the infantry could charge
into the enemy trench
and take it over.
This particular map also
has a unique history.
It's from the G and M Collection
by General Charles Summerall.
Summerall ordered an
attack on November 10, 1918.
Does that sound significant to you?
Because November 11 is the day
that the armistice is
going to take place.
He ordered an attack,
because he was of the mind
that the Germans were faking,
that this armistice was baloney.
They just wanted time to rest
and recover, and that we needed
to keep the heat on them.
So he orders troops to
cross the Meuse River
and to take German
positions on the other side.
In this attack, some
360 plus Marines --
not part of the Army but under their
command and some of the best troops
that we had at the time -- die.
It becomes a scandal
back in Washington.
Why did you send Marines
across a river
where the Germans had machine
guns on the other side,
to die on the next-to-last
day of the war?
Pershing and other military
leaders came to Summerall's defense.
They said, "We didn't know if
the Germans were going to give up
or not, and we had to
keep the heat on them."
And Summerall was exonerated for any
wrongdoing, although the families
of the servicemen who died hated
him tremendously for this order.
And this, again, is part of
the Summerall papers in the G
and M Collection that any
one of you want to come in
and review, it's available.
Since artillery was so
dangerous, it's important
to locate the enemy's artillery,
and I talked about aerial
photography was one means,
patrol was the other.
But often, those methodologies
were insufficient to map
where the enemy's artillery
might in fact be.
Both sides develop something
called "sound ranging,"
and the technologies among
the different armies varied
and I'm going to generalize
what they did here.
This map by the U.S.
Army, using sound ranging
to detect German batteries
across the front lines.
Microphones would be set
up along predefined points.
And when a gun would fire,
the sound would travel
and reach those microphones
at different times.
They would calculate how long the
sound took to reach the vibration,
to reach the microphone, and
triangulate where the gun might be.
This was so effective that they
could triangulate an enemy gun
within about 20 yards
by the end of the war.
So what that meant was that if you
shoot, you got to move your gun.
If you got to move your gun, that
means you're exposing your gun
to reconnaissance, so
you better make it count.
So this but the Germans, in
particular, in a predicament
because when they would shoot,
we would fire a counter
battery barrage right away
to blast their guns.
They would try to move the
guns to a new hiding place.
We would immediately send up
airplanes and look for them,
and we were hot on their
tail and they knew it.
So trenches, of course, then, it
should be stated, is more important
because artillery was
so devastating.
Where could you safely put
troops then on the front line
if these maps were so accurate,
and 60% of all casualties
are caused by big guns.
How do we keep the troops safe?
And it was the trench.
The trench was -- we think
of it as a terrible place.
It's muddy, it's dirty,
it's got rats,
all kind of disease
in these trenches.
Who wants to be in a trench?
But on a World War I battlefield,
the trench, generally speaking,
is the safest place to be.
The problem with the
trench is getting out of it.
And when they blow the whistle
and they say you've got to go
over the top to attack the enemy,
men were mowed down within feet
of their own trench line, because
the enemy had it pre-sited,
meaning they knew where
you would come out.
There were snipers, machine
guns, their artillery,
and they were ready to blast away.
This map here is what
we call a trench map.
It's a German trench map.
We have British, American, and
many other versions of trench maps
in the collections of
the Library of Congress.
Trenches of World War I often were
organized what they call "in depth,"
meaning there was a main line
of defense, a secondary line,
and finally a third line.
The idea here was that
that the enemy attack.
We have light forces in
the front to screen them.
Should we need to, we would
fall back to the second line.
The advantage of this is
they sent men over the top.
They had taken this position.
We fall back here.
Our artillery is back here.
We have this all mapped out
very nicely, and we're happy
to blast our own front
line trench to bits,
now that the enemy has occupied it.
And this was a trick that
the Germans would use.
And the Americans, because
we entered the war in 1917,
we were a little bit
slow to pick up on this,
although our Allies
warned us about it.
And we would occupy
their trenches and stay.
And the French were like, "You
need to keep going forward."
And after a few blasts -- and
this happened a few times --
our commanders adjusted
and said, "You can't stay.
You need to move to the
second line and to safety."
Incidentally, this map is
from the area of Verdun,
an important battlefield
of World War I.
Verdun was a very political battle.
The Germans said in 1916 when
they were unable to take France
by mobile warfare, that
they would wear the Allies
out through attrition.
And they said, "The French
will defend a very historical
and sacred city of Verdun with
as many troops as it takes.
So we will force them
into this cauldron
and kill as many as possible."
And the German field
commanders were appalled
by this high command decision
because they said, "You're asking me
to order my men to fight,
not to gain an objective
or ground -- something tangible.
You're asking my men
just to go out and fight
and kill until they get killed.
How can we sustain this?"
Whereas on the French side, they
said, "This is our territory.
This is our land."
It became a sacred battle
for the honor of France,
and they staved off the
German offensive here.
And it was a high cost
of life to both sides.
The ground was virtually just
stagnant -- the trench lines.
One of the last maps I want
to show you of the war here is
of the armistice, 11/11/1918.
This map was initially a secret
map showing the final disposition
of forces as they would stand
when the armistice was to begin.
The Allies had in the field at
this time some 280 plus divisions
that were well fed, rested,
high morale, good supplies.
The Germans had 180
under-strength divisions.
They were called division on paper,
but maybe they were half
strength, even less.
They weren't getting food.
Their guns were being worn out.
The barrels were so worn that
they couldn't shoot straight.
They realized that the Americans
have now come into the war in 1970
and advancing against us.
And Americans, incidentally,
put some 2 million troops
into battle against the Germans.
It was just too much.
They were tired, fighting
since 1914.
The Americans come along,
very fresh, energized.
They bring this new momentum.
The Allies start the hundred days
campaign against the Germans,
and it culminates with
this armistice on the 11th.
So Germany before this happened,
wanted to look for a way out.
They said, "What can we do
to preserve what we
have taken in this war?"
And I know I've been focusing on the
Western front, but I want to bring
in a map from the Eastern
front because it is important
to understand the German
psychology at the time,
and then leading to World War II.
So the map here, this says,
"Our march in the East.
The facts versus the lies."
The Germans took all this
territory on the Eastern front
from the Russians in this area
that eventually would
become Poland, okay.
They were hugely successful
against the Russians.
And in fact, the allowed
Lenin who was in Switzerland,
passage to Germany into Russia.
And they gave him money
with the thought being
that this guy is crazy enough
to bring followers to his side
and to get the Russians
out of the war.
And he was successful.
The Russians had sent
millions to their deaths
on the front lines,
lives of casualties.
They didn't want to fight anymore.
There were tired.
The Communists took control.
They negotiated a peace
with the Germans,
and the Germans took all
this land, the Baltics,
Ukraine, all this, Poland.
This was all the German
Empire in the East.
And we see that here
also on this map printed
by the United States Committee
of Public Information.
See all this territory?
The pink is the land
which the Germans
and the Austro-Hungarians
extended their empires,
Belgium, portions of France.
This was in 1917.
And the Germans say at this point
in time, they start talking,
"Let's settle this, Woodrow Wilson.
You're the great negotiator
for peace.
You want us to sit down
and talk about this?
We're happy to end the war now.
Because the Germans realized,
"We can't push them away.
We've tried our best.
What can we do?
So let's negotiate."
But the Germans had
infuriated the United States.
As you know, they sunk
the Lusitania.
They were sinking other ships
of ours, acts of sabotage
within the United States such as
blowing up the ammunition depot
at Black Tom Island in New Jersey.
Up here in Baltimore, there
is a place called Hansa Haus.
It still exists, and the
Germans had a legation there.
They brought in spies by submarine
to recruit German-Americans
to engage in acts of
spying and sabotage.
And then, they tried this plan
called the Zimmerman Telegram
which you may have heard about,
where they wanted to enlist the help
of Mexico to occupy
the United States
so it wouldn't come to Europe.
All this had come to the attention
of the American leadership,
and when these overtures for
peace started to continue,
Woodrow Wilson was pushed
beyond his limits and said no,
to the relief of the
British and the French.
No, we're not going to
entertain any peace overtures.
If you want peace, you're going
to move back within your borders
and you're going to be
responsible for paying for this war.
And this Committee on Public
Information was the American
propaganda apparatus, and would
put out all these different kind
of publications about teaching
Americans about Prussian militarism
and the rape of Belgium and
all these kind of things.
And maps were one of the means
which they communicated why
America ought to be in this war.
As you know, America was
very culturally diverse.
Millions of Germans living
in the United States,
people from the Austro-Hungarian
Empire, Irish.
These folks necessarily
didn't have a vested interest
in seeing England succeed,
for example.
How do we communicate
to our population why
this war is important?
And these kind of propaganda
maps were used by both sides.
Germany, as we know,
eventually gives up its military,
has over the reins to
a civilian government,
and since them the Versailles
to negotiate for peace.
It's a convenient way to blame
them for anything that goes wrong,
because the German military had
held the power of the country
in their hands since 1914
once they went to war,
and it was effectively a
military dictatorship in Germany.
Now they send these
civilian diplomats to France,
and the German diplomats are
shocked by the terms of the peace.
They said first off, you must
accept total blame for the war.
You must pay reparations.
Your proud Prussian militarism, your
German army, is going to be reduced
to 100,000 men with
no heavy equipment,
essentially a territorial defense.
So that's the heart and soul
of the Germans is their
army, their military.
It hits at the gut.
And on top of that, you're
going to lose territory.
They're forced to concede
Alsace-Lorraine to the French.
The Rhineland and the
Ruhr Valley here
in the East is Germany's
industrial heartland.
This is where the big
weapons factories are.
This is going to be occupied --
this surprises a lot of
folks -- by American troops.
In the South -- French,
British, and Belgian.
We're going to occupy
that for several years,
and the French will be
the ones there the longest
until the early 20s
before they withdraw.
In the East, land is
going to be taken
from Germany and given to Poland.
As you may know, during World War I
Poland does not exist as a country.
Its historical territory was
divided between the Germans,
Austro-Hungarian, and the Russians.
Woodrow Wilson makes it a point
of war in his famous 14 Points
that there must be a free
Poland with access to the sea.
How are they going
to make that happen?
They're going to take
land from the Germans,
because the Russians are not
going to be giving up any land,
so the land comes from the Germans.
A new country forms, Czechoslovakia,
and within it is an area
called the Sudeten land
where Germans are living and forced
to live under Czech authority.
So this creates a situation where
millions of Germans are now forced
to live under the authority
of other governments.
Germans are blamed entirely for
the war, rightly or wrongly,
and their proud military has
been taken away from them.
German soldiers, unlike their Allied
counterparts, when they go home,
they don't take off their uniforms.
They stay together and they
form barracks and cities
and they call themselves Freikorps,
and they act like they're still
in the Army, and they don't want
to be dismissed from their jobs.
And among these Freikorps is
a corporal named Adolf Hitler.
Hitler had the very dangerous job
in World War I of being a runner.
He would leave the safety
of the trench and go back
to the headquarters and
communicate what was going on,
often in the middle
of artillery barrage.
The folks who did this
didn't live very long often.
It was very dangerous
to expose one's self
out of a trench under fire.
He received medals for
his bravery, and he,
like many other German military,
were thinking, "Why did we give up?"
Right? "We have all
this land in the East."
Right now at the time of
Versailles, their army was still
in situ in these areas, okay.
They didn't want to move out.
They said, "Grant us this land.
We won it.
We paid for with our blood."
And when they were finally forced
to come back home, the notion was,
"We're stabbed in the back.
We did this for country,
for the Fatherland,
and now we have been forced to
give it up against our will."
And so, thinking about the next
war, in the minds of Germans,
people like Hitler, and
veterans of the First World War.
We think, "Oh, it's
crazy to invade Russia."
But they felt, "We did
it once and we won.
We can do it again."
Something to think about.
And I think maps tell that
story better than anything else.
And lastly, I'm going to
with this illustration
of saying, "To end all wars."
Right? We see that they are going to
bury German militarism and the fires
of hell, and Uncle Sam is within
your gleefully with a shovel,
and his top hat says, "Lusitania."
This image can be seen online at
the Library of Congress' webpage.
And Allied powers are happily
depositing German militarism
to the grave, which we know comes
back again in the Second World War.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Richard Pflederer: Okay,
let's please take our seats,
and I'd like to introduce
our speaker.
I think you'll agree that the first
talk by Ryan had a heavy focus
on the US, very appropriate.
We're going to now have a
speaker from Great Britain.
Professor Peter Doyle has come over.
He's a PhD, of course, and
he's a visiting professor
at the University College in London.
His topic is Gallipoli
and the physical aspects,
the geographical aspects
of that battle.
It went on for almost a year.
It was a disaster personally
for the First Lord
of the Admiralty, Winston Churchill.
And it has a strategic,
let's say, outlook.
Ryan had described those Central
Powers as being basically four --
Germany, Austro-Hungarian Empire,
Bulgaria, and the Ottoman Empire.
If this Gallipoli campaign
had been successful,
it would have at least
separated out the Ottomans.
So, Peter Doyle has spoken at West
Point at least twice that I know of.
He's got a very interesting talk.
Without any further ado,
I will invite him up now.
And also say that the
Q&A will be combined
with the two speakers immediately
after Professor Doyle's talk.
Peter?
[ Applause ]
>> Peter Doyle: Can we
pick up these lights?
>> Richard Pflederer: Yeah,
he's going to get it right now.
>> Peter Doyle: Okay, well,
difficult act to follow,
Ryan's exposition on
the First World War.
So, I'm going to try
to follow that up.
I was going to draw upon a number
of things that Ryan said today.
I wanted to concentrate on the
battle which has a great deal
of mythology associated with it.
I'm also going to be
looking at a map
that that became a
scapegoat for failure.
So, here we have a map which was
used not only to plan a campaign,
but one that was also blamed
for the failure of a campaign.
It's very important.
So obviously from my perspective,
I know where Gallipoli is
and I know what it's about,
but I'd like to know how many
of you have even heard of Gallipoli?
So, can we get a show of hands?
Excellent, so I have
an informed audience.
And how many of you think that
it was only the Australians
that fought at Gallipoli?
Okay, so still an informed audience.
That's good.
So what I want to do then
today is to take you through
and examine the concept of
Gallipoli, of terrain, of maps,
on our failure in the
Dardanelles in 1915.
Now, I'm talking about mythology.
The mythology of Gallipoli is
one of the most important aspects
of the historiography
of the campaign.
What we're looking at is a pathology
that makes its way
into popular culture.
We have an American comic book
from the 1960s that summarizes,
in effect, what the
Gallipoli campaign is about.
Tens of thousands, it says, who
died and fell on hard beaches there
at Gallipoli in the Dardanelles.
It was a campaign that
was doomed to fail.
And if you look at this, the
mythology goes that the campaign,
of course, were doomed to
fail because of its geography.
It was also doomed to fail because
of its planner, and the planning
that went into that campaign.
And specifically, it was
also a let down by its maps.
And so, if we follow the mythology
through, was this actually true
as the American comic
book here portrays.
"I say, old chap, this map
of Gallipoli is only
a hundred years old."
"Probably nothing has
changed since then."
Is this really the way to run a war?
So I want to examine
what the truth is.
I can say categorically at this
point, that without Gallipoli,
we probably wouldn't have the
success in the invasion of Normandy.
But really, was that something that
we want to portray Gallipoli as?
So let's look at the road to
Gallipoli, the road to the war.
Now, as Ryan has eloquently
put forward to us,
this is a war that
has erupted in Europe.
A war that has seen all
of the alliances putting
themselves together, and we've heard
about the Schieffen plan.
We're also bringing in the
personality of one man,
one very important man, and
that man is Winston Churchill.
Winston Churchill, as you
know, is a man who is credited
in the Second World War as being
a great orator and a great leader
and somebody who saved the British
from destruction in many ways.
But what we're seeing is,
during this great war,
he was what was known as the
First Lord of the Admiralty,
typically British, I guess.
The leader, the civilian
leader of the Navy.
And he wasn't happy that
one of these enemies --
that is, the Ottoman Empire --
had the audacity to have two ships
from the Germans, the Goeben and the
Breslau, selling to the straights
of the Dardanelles, pitching
up at Constantinople,
which is present day Istanbul.
And this was thumbing
the nose at the British.
That precipitated perhaps
the alliance
with the war and also
following that.
It probably would be better
without the light, that's all right.
I don't mind being behind that.
>> Excuse me just one second.
This light has been turned
on because the people
who are filming this say they
just have to have that light
on for the -- So if
it's possible to move
so that glare isn't hitting you --
>> Peter Doyle: Yeah, it's more the
slides that I'm concerned about.
>> Try aiming that light possibly to
the left a little bit then, please.
>> Peter Doyle: Shall I continue?
>> Just wait, just
one second, please.
>> Peter Doyle: Certainly.
[ Background Conversations ]
>> Richard Pflederer:
Carry on, Peter.
>> Peter Doyle: Thank you.
Yes, I will, amongst the
arguments in the corridor too.
That's interesting.
Anyway, thank you very much.
So, Winston Churchill, the two chips
have gone through, the Germans,
their influence over
the Ottoman Turks meant
that the Ottoman Turks
were now an enemy.
And Winston Churchill, a man
who had a Navy at his disposal,
and let's not put too
fine a point on it --
it was the finest and strongest
Navy in the world at that point.
So Winston Churchill has this Navy.
He wants to do something with this.
Not only does he have a
Navy, he creates an army
out of this [inaudible] sailors.
He was constantly thinking
about how he could take the war.
And one of the ideas was he
could knock the Ottoman Empire
out of the war using a Navy.
So he hopped back a hundred
years or so to the concept
of forcing the Dardanelles,
the idea of creating a Navy --
see if I can get this to work --
creating a Navy that would be able
to force its way through
the Dardanelles.
There is the Dardanelles passage.
There is the Gallipoli Peninsula.
These are a line of ships that would
literally force their way through,
bombarding the fortresses
as they went.
Now, that sounds great on paper.
The trouble is, is that admirals,
once they start to lose ships,
those ships full of men, thousands
of men, then the admirals taste
for forcing their way through
started to wane a little bit.
And so, by the 18th of
March 1915, a day which is
in present-day Turkey
a public holiday,
we see the failure of the campaign.
No longer could they force the
way through the Dardanelles,
pitch up at Constantinople, and
do what the British do best,
which is threaten the city there and
hope that they would be defeated.
Ships were sunk.
Men were lost.
The Navy turned back, and it was
relied upon for boots on the ground.
You can imagine when I
give this at West Point,
that's where I get the
biggest cheer -- for that.
[ Laughter ]
So, the Navy withdrew.
The Army has to come --
the Army and the Marines.
And landings therefore on a hostile
shore would then be necessary.
And if you look at any of the
doctrines of amphibious landing,
landing on a hostile shore is
of the most difficult order.
So it was a gamble.
This look at this gamble.
Here, we can see the peculiar
shape of the Gallipoli Peninsula.
We can see the narrowness
of the Dardanelle Straits
and we can see its location
there in Turkey, in Europe.
Turkey had been shrinking in size
because of various Balkan wars.
The landings weren't there to
actually just take the Peninsula.
The landings were there to silence
the guns and remove the minefields
to allow the Navy to do its job.
So they were actually
supporting the Navy.
There were some possible
landing places.
These lending places had
been surveyed already.
They had been in place since
the early 19th century.
At this location here to the
neck of the peninsula Bulair,
ironically this was
a fortified zone,
fortified by the Anglo-French
Army during the Crimean War,
when the Ottoman Turks were allies
to the French and the British.
There was also the
possibility of landing
on the Asiatic shore,
as it was called.
Remember, this is the junction of
two continents, Asia and Europe.
So, there's a possibility
of landing there.
But if you land there, you're
going to get lots and lots
of angry Turks on your
back, in effect.
And so, remaining are these
beaches here across the peninsula,
both at the point here at Cape
Helles to this location here
at Gaba Tepe, or here, an
unknown place in Suvla Bay.
All of those things, landing
places had been surveyed
and were in position.
And by April 25, 1915,
just under a month
after the Naval attempt had
failed, the British, French,
and Australians landed here.
Did you know the French
were at Gallipoli?
No? One thing, just the one thing.
So we can see Anzac -- Australian
and New Zealand Army Corps --
the British 29th division --
a strange echo, if you like,
of the 29th division at Omaha Beach.
There are comparable issues there.
And the French Corps de
Orient landing there to take
on the Gallipoli Peninsula.
Now, one thing that we have that
they didn't have was any kind
of satellite imagery, obviously.
What we can see from this satellite
image is a very peculiarity
of this landscape, the challenge
of the geography of Gallipoli.
Well, first and foremost, you
have the distance you have
to travel in a straight line.
It's 230 miles from the
entrance to the Dardanelles
to Istanbul (Constantinople).
But getting there means jinking your
way through here and a long way,
and you can see the offset and all
the strange coastline of Gallipoli.
That's because we have the
junction of two tectonic plates,
and therefore lots
and lots of breaks
which have created this
parallel coastline and fractures.
So we can see how we get these
lines of fractures which are picking
out for us the landscape
of Gallipoli.
That was going to cause real
problems for the British
and Anzac troops and
French who landed there.
It also means that we have a rugged
terrain because as the faults
and fractures operate, so
they uplift the landscape.
So just like the bad land topography
that we have in your Southwest,
similar kind of situations
and uplifting landscape
and down cutting, we
have exactly the same
in miniature here in Gallipoli.
And so, understanding this terrain
was essential to military success.
If you look at the doctrine
of amphibious landing
from your own United
States military,
you will see that that is written
large in understanding that.
Because those men, with
their boots on the ground,
have to fight not only
against the enemy
but also against the topography.
And how are they going to know
what the topography is about?
Well, they do that through maps.
So, this is where the
map myth comes in.
Here we have General Sir Ian
Hamilton, ramrod straight
as you can see in typical
British fashion.
He was the most senior general
that was not directly
employed at that time.
In Kitchener, who was Secretary of
State for War, was his superior.
Hamilton looked up to
Kitchener and a great way.
Kitchener was a man
who took no fools
and listened to no kind of excuses.
Yet, Hamilton made those excuses.
Hamilton was put in charge
of the Gallipoli campaign.
He was really experienced.
He fought in the Anglo Boer
War, and yet he wrote --
he was a very literary general --
he wrote after the war these words.
"Ten long years of General Staff
created after the Boer war.
Where are your plans for
an amphibious landing?"
None, he is saying.
"And it may have well been
the moon that I'm invading
because I just don't
have any information."
Now, one has to ask
oneself, is this true?
Written in 1920.
Remember that after the failure
of the Dardanelles of Gallipoli,
Hamilton's career, esteemed and
distinguished, was in tatters.
What we do know is
what he has written
down about how he was
instructed to invade.
The problem is, who is it
that's writing about this?
So we can see here,
Brigadier-General Aspinall-Oglander
was a colonel,
senior staff officer,
with Hamilton in 1915.
And so, when he's writing here,
he's defending his old chief.
And what he's saying is that
Hamilton, when he was briefed
by Kitchener, very, very brief
because Kitchener didn't mince
words, he got some instructions.
In essence, go and
take the Dardanelles.
A handbook of the Army
-- Well, that's okay.
That's only a couple
of years out of date.
Everything like this will
ultimately be out of date.
But two other elements
-- a prewar report
of the Dardanelles defenses kind of
implying that it was substandard,
and a map which is specifically
considered to be inaccurate.
In other words, their setting up the
mythology that the map is at fault,
trying to hide perhaps that
Hamilton might have been at fault.
So, what did they actually get?
Well, we have the War Office
Handbooks that were provided.
But we also have a whole range of
other reports, 1905, 1909, 1908.
All of these things
had been prepared
because Britain was cautious
about the Ottoman Empire.
Remember that Great
Britain was involved in many
of the Middle Eastern
states and Egypt
in particular with the Suez Canal.
Oh, and there was that map, the
map which creates the mythology.
This map of two sheets of 1 inch to
1 mile map, 1 to 63,360 scale map.
So, the corrective
to this is one man,
another general, General Callwell.
Callwell, cautious in
his British speech,
director of military operations
in the British War Office,
and a man who had been
involved in military planning
and had actually been
involved in the preparation
of those military reports in the
early part of the 20th century.
So, if we try and unpack this,
Hamilton had been informed
with information as to the
various possible landing points.
He's saying Hamilton knew
about this information
which was fairly correct
information,
and that fairly correct
information about the interior.
So again, he's saying,
"Yes, I'm being cautious."
But he's also talking about the map.
He's saying that in the
absence of regular surveys,
the maps supplied were
necessarily untrustworthy.
What he means is the only maps
that were available were yes,
inaccurate, but that's all we had.
That's the necessary inaccuracy
here with respect to the ground.
So Callwell is saying, "Hamilton,
you're overstating this."
Let's see whether what's
being said is true.
Okay, so let's examine to the
components of the briefing.
The War Office secret report on
certain many places in Turkey.
Remember Hamilton saying, you know,
"I didn't have any information.
I didn't know where to go.
I didn't have anything that would
allow me to land in Constantinople."
Well, what about the map?
The War Office map, the Geographical
Section of the General Staff 2285,
1908 map, the map of the
Peninsula of Gallipoli.
Okay, so let's look at
"Certain Many Places in Turkey."
This is a fat, big
report with two sections.
He was drawn up in response to
one of the many, many disputes.
This one the Aqaba Crisis
of 1906, which is a dispute
between drawing the boundary between
Egypt and Syria -- sounds familiar.
The diplomatic argument between
Britain and the Ottoman Empire,
which meant that they needed
maps to provide information
for any future boots on the ground.
A report which has
lots of information
about the Gallipoli Peninsula, about
locations there in the Dardanelles,
the Dardanelles itself, and
the Buliar lines as mentioned.
It's a book that Hamilton is
saying has barely any information,
and yet we have maps and
plans really valuable,
lots of detail here.
And topographical panoramas.
You remember this is an amphibious
landing, and for sure what you want
to see is what you see from
the sea, moving on to the land.
And so, there's topographical
panoramas.
We also have the very, very detailed
specifics of fortifications.
This is Seddel Bahr, at the
entrance to the Dardanelles.
And panoramic photographs
with annotations,
once again providing information.
Let's remember, this is 1914,
1915 that this is being operated.
This had been developed in 1909,
we're not a long way from the detail
that we can provide in
1916 [inaudible], again,
as Ryan has explained to us.
Okay, so was this information
any good?
Well, the report gave
all the details
of the batteries, of the defenses.
So sure, it's good.
It also identified the nature
of the terrain from the sea.
Well, it's an amphibious landing.
That's what you want.
And for sure, it influenced the
choice of the landing beaches,
and Hamilton deployed
that information.
And yet, Hamilton postwar is saying
he didn't have enough information.
Well, he certainly
used that information.
What about maps?
Maps that the Phillips Society
and the Library of Congress
who I'm very grateful to for
bringing me here to do this,
a great honor for me
to talk about it.
Let's look at that map.
Yet another product of the
Aqaba Crisis, derived though
from an earlier survey, a survey
made by the French in 1854.
I will pronounce this
particularly well,
but it's the "Carte de la
Presqu'lle de Gallipoli,"
okay, produced in 1854.
We've heard again from Ryan about
what was available to the allies
in 1914 and '15 in France, a
map of similar quality to this.
This had been surveyed in
1854 during the Crimean War,
and this is a 1 to 50,000 scale.
So actually, this is a larger
scale map that had been produced
for the mainland of France,
constructed most likely
with theodolite and plane
table to give the angles,
to get the locations, similar
to domestic survey
that was carried out.
And at a scale of 1 to 50,000, it
had contour intervals of 10 meters,
giving you a map which has
a fair amount of detail.
So let's look at this map.
It's fairly handsome.
It's black and white.
Those of you in the audience
who are acquainted with that,
which I would count as
everybody, would understand
that this map is telling you this
is a tough terrain to work on.
Straightaway, you are
identifying the ruggedness
of the terrain by the
contour interval.
You're picking out the readings.
You're picking out the way in
which the water is flowing.
Across here, you can see the
gray location of high points.
There are terrain annotations here.
There is a feature
called Gully Ravine
which became a major
part of the battle.
And we can see here Achi Baba,
a location which became a British
obsession but never, ever taken.
I spoke to Turks on the ground.
They said this would be Verdun.
The British would never take this.
It was always going to
be in Ottoman hands.
So, at 1 to 50,000 scale,
equivalent in quality.
Was this really the map
that has no information
that Hamilton is talking about?
Well, to be fair, we're
looking at something
that the British thought
they could improve on,
which is probably a bad thing.
That map was regularized.
The British wanted it to
be 1 inch to 1 mile 1 mile.
You measure an inch, on
your map you've gone a mile.
So they make this really strange
adjustment to 1 to 63,360 scale map.
And they also increase
the contour interval
to 31 meters, a hundred feet.
That immediately creates something
which looks much more open,
perhaps difficult to
see in this light,
but you can see how there
are fewer contours here.
Now you, as experienced
individuals, will know full well
that even this map has information
upon it because these contour lines
at a hundred meters separation
still quite close together,
still picking out a ravine, still
picking out the major points.
So this is Gully Ravine.
This is Achi Baba.
There are terrain annotations
on the full sheet also,
so it is giving information.
But the change in scale
does cause problems,
and those subdue the
terrain features.
So I've talked a lot about
the mythology of the map,
but maybe now I am erring
towards -- Well, hold on a minute,
maybe this map is not as
good as I had first made out.
Was it valuable?
And there's a corrective that I
have to point out to you here.
Well, the map depicted the same
features as the French one before.
The French one was still
available to the British.
The French map was
the only medium --
I would call it necessarily a large
scale map -- that was available.
There was no choice but to use it.
You can't conjure up.
You can't do a satellite survey.
You can't conjure up an
aerial photographic sweep.
This was enemy territory.
And by the way, we're talking about
1914-1915 where your aircraft,
as Ryan has pointed out,
are very, very flimsy.
But the problem was
that the redrawing
of this map created the
mythology of the scapegoat,
that this had an effect of subduing
the features of the landscape.
Okay, great.
I'm thinking, okay, well, why didn't
they just use some other maps?
You know, if that one's no
good, use something else.
Maybe the story about
them combing the bookshops
in Alexandria was correct.
To be honest, what
map are available?
Hardly any, if any.
There are some prewar surveys
carried out by British military
and naval officers, often
surreptitiously, clandestine,
because of these crises
that I've mentioned.
There was a single
small-scale location map,
very similar to the image I
showed you of the satellite scale.
And tellingly, there were
no large-scale Ottoman maps.
So, not even the Ottomans
had a map, be it to a scale
that could be used
in a military sense.
The 1 to 25,000 survey, very similar
to the scales used for military maps
that Ryan has referred to, was
completed only on the eve of war.
So that meant that
the British 1 inch map
and its derivatives was the only
map available to the Allies,
so bemoaning it is yes, it
is a difficult map to use
but it's the only one you've got.
So if it's the only one
you've got, get on and use it.
Okay, so here you go.
This is what's known as
the quarter inch map.
This is the map that
shows 1 to 250,000 scale.
It's pretty useful and that
it shows you how Gallipoli
and the Peninsula works in
the Dardanelle Straights.
It was printed in 1908, so again,
it's a derivative of those maps
and its strategic, not tactical.
We've heard this again from Ryan,
in that different maps
are doing different jobs.
This was issued to the British
forces because it gave them an idea
of where they were in the world,
and therefore they needed to be able
to get larger scale
maps to work it out.
It still was used though,
as you can see here,
with the little red annotations
showing the landing beaches
in the southern part of [Inaudible].
Okay, what about the older surveys?
These are the ones
surreptitiously carried out
or done under diplomatic cover.
There was one by Captain Grover of
the British Royal Engineers in 1876.
Grover was operating under
diplomatic support because, again,
the British and French were allied
to the Ottomans at this point.
There were also surveys of
the Bulair lines, these very,
very important fortifications across
the narrowest part of that location.
So there was lots of that
information available.
I want to take you to
looking at Grover's survey.
This is entirely prescient,
because what Grover is talking
about are some of the
landing beaches,
because those landing beaches which
had appeared in the reports early on
and the reports in 1909 were
the self-same landing beaches
that would be used again.
The reason for that is,
they're the only landing beaches
on this rugged terrain.
So Grover carried out a rapid
reconnaissance of the coastline
between two locations that
will become familiar to you.
This place Gaba Tepe here, and this
location here, Fisherman's Hut,
which still exists
today on this coast.
If you look at this,
we can see something
which looks fairly impressive.
It's a scale of 4 inches to a
mile, 1 to 15,000 plus or minus.
But what we get is a sense of
the rapidity of the mapping here.
It's a stylized form.
We don't see very much
the rugged terrain
that I will demonstrate
to you in a moment.
We're getting really a sense of
this relatively smooth point.
This is the heights to Sari Bair,
which is a mountain
area in this location.
So, getting a sense of
stylized, smoothed contours,
really done in haste, but we do
have topographical annotations.
Scrub, impossible cliffs, difficult
beaches, precipitous cliffs,
that kind of thing -- all of
which was available to Hamilton.
So, I've mentioned about the maps
that were produced
on the eve of war.
And here we have an Ottoman map
with a beautiful Ottoman script --
Ottoman calligraphy, of course, is
amongst the finest in the world.
And what we see here is the
map of the Cape Helles area
that was once reputedly owned
by General Liman von Sanders,
the German commander of the
Ottoman troops in this location.
This resides in the National
Archives in the United Kingdom
and the originals in the
equivalent in Australia.
This emphasizes the fact that these
maps might have been available
to somebody as senior
as Liman von Sanders,
but they were just not available
to the British, French,
or other allies.
The reason for that is, they were
literally surveyed between 1912
and 1914, and the issue of them
was probably only in 1914 and 1915.
So, pretty much they're having some
intelligence services that have
to do a lot of hard work
to get a hold of these maps
if they had not actually yet
been issued to their own troops.
So once again, we have the
only map that's available
to the Allies is the ill-fated
and godforsaken 1 inch map.
Okay, so what I want to do now is to
take you in more detail down to two
of the main locations of
the Gallipoli Peninsula.
We're talking about what is now
known as Anzac Day, April 25, 1915,
when the landings were made
of the wild colonial boys
of the Australians
and New Zealanders.
They were the ill-prepared,
unpracticed, untested troops
with a little bit of
colonial verve sent to fight
up these really difficult terrain.
In the South, the British 29th
division, professional troops,
fought long and hard in
Britain's small wars,
sent to take the biggest
nut to crack at Cape Helles.
An idea behind them was to rise
up the high ground, join forces,
[inaudible], dispose of the guns
and dispose of the minefields.
That's the idea behind it.
The terrain here is
different in both locations.
So, this wonderful spot -- I had
to Photoshop my son out of this
to make it look more military,
but he was only a little boy then.
This wonderful spot, a magnificent
beach, is very similar in many ways
to the killing beaches of Omaha.
We have cliffs, we have
narrow slot-like drawers,
as the Americans would call
them after Omaha Beach.
And we would imagine here
the men coming ashore,
wading ashore here
into the face of hell.
So, what was the plan at Helles,
sending the most experienced troops?
Well, it was to split the force
because what we have is Hamilton
has a large force of 80,000,
but not large enough really
to take the Peninsula.
I'll come into that in a moment.
He split them according to
these very, very small beaches.
They were narrow, they
were constraining.
They were that way inclined
because of the drainage each went
in a rectilinear pattern,
down the line of the Peninsula
because it's lining
up with the faults,
the fractures, the
tectonic features.
We can see an open -- what
we could call a glacis,
very typical of any fortification.
And we can see the rising
ground, and the idea here is
that there are no artillery
pieces being landed at this point.
It's an amphibious landing.
There are no tanks.
There is no chance of
bringing field guns.
You need the Navy to do their job.
A naval gunnery is low trajectory.
So you've got a low-rising slope.
You can hopefully sweep
that with those guns.
The idea behind it -- to get to the
prize of dominating the narrows,
of allowing those Navy
boys to get through.
But that's assuming that
nothing is happening on land.
And so, Hamilton is
writing almost begrudgingly,
how dare they organize for defense?
"The Peninsula is being fortified
and many Turks work every night
on trenches, redoubts,
and entanglements."
How dare they?
Because the Turks and the Germans
who are operating here
knew what they were doing.
The Turks have fought many wars
before this -- the Balkan wars.
They had fought against
the Italians.
They fought against the Bulgarians.
They fought against everybody, and
they had lost a lot of territory.
So they were fairly battle hardened.
They knew what they were doing.
The trench lines here were
following the contours.
There were strong points,
machine-gun posts, barbed wire put
in position to stop the
troops coming ashore.
There were hillsides.
Again, very, very similar to
the kinds of fortifications
that were put in place
before Normandy,
with Rommel placing his defensive
positions on those D-Day beaches.
So, the Turks were ready.
They were also capable and
they were able, of course,
to use the terrain effectively.
So that meant that the
1 inch map, of course,
needed extra embellishment.
So there were reconnaissance
sketches.
Here's a reconnaissance sketch
in the National Archives
in the UK showing some
interpretation
on the map -- very much sketchy.
And there were also aerial
interpretations literally
with an aviator in a very, very
rudimentary aircraft with a map
on his lap, drawing on the position
of trenches and other things,
because we're not getting
aerial photography
at this particular
stage of the campaign.
Yes, we have panoramic sketches
because every military
officer today, as then,
was trained in the art
of panoramic sketching.
And we can see just how difficult
these individual landing beaches
would be in the face
of such a terrain.
Now, I want to look at the map.
I've said about this a mythology.
I sort of overemphasized that.
Let's actually now take
a more objective view.
Did the map do its job?
Well, here's the French one.
This is at the tip
of the Dardanelles.
And here's the British one.
And I think as you'll see, there's
a change in the view of that map.
What we have is a much
more open terrain.
Doesn't seem to have the same
level of detail as the French one.
That's because of the contouring
and the change in scale.
We can see one or two hill features,
Hill 114, Hill 138, and Hill 141.
These were all named by the British.
On the French, we can
pick out contouring.
It gives us a sense of
the hills and [inaudible].
On the British, just spot heights.
I should also point
out that each one
of the beaches is a concave
situation, and if you look
in any manual of amphibious warfare,
you avoid these like the plague
because they create
[inaudible] fire from two sides.
There's also just about picked
out on the French one a kind
of feature known as Guezi Baba,
which is totally absent
on the British map.
Why does this matter?
Well, let's look at one of the
maps that was captured in April
and May 1915 as the
Allies started to land.
This is an Ottoman map, mapped
to the scale of 1 to 25,000.
British cartographers looked
at this and said, "Yeah,
it looks a little bit too good
to be true, but pretty accurate."
We can see all of the
features on here.
Hill 114 with nice contouring.
Hill 138, similar kind
of contouring.
We see that Hill 138
and Guezi Baba nearby,
part of a similar terrain feature.
That was completely missed on
the maps and the annotations.
But let's not forget these maps
were not available to the Allies.
So what is this matter?
Well, this is a map that was
carried out by Commander Douglas.
He was a naval commander
and cartographer.
He did a survey post war --
well, post to the initial landings
during the campaign to give a sense
of what the British had to face.
There was a lot of sort of
recrimination and discussion.
He puts on all of the trench lines.
He shows the point that has the
British land at W and V beaches.
The intention was that they
would join up and join forces,
also with men coming ashore here
which I haven't put on -- X beach.
They would then take the Turks in
the rear there, remove the threat,
and push on up the Peninsula.
But what's been forgotten
here is the effect
of that missing fortification.
So yes, the map failed
in this instance.
So, let's look at that.
We can see here the concavity
of that, the bowl shape,
the sense that the
trenches built by the Turks.
Follow the line of that
bowl, with the obvious effect
that when the British
landed, they thought,
"Right, there's no fire here.
Everything's fine."
As soon as they got on the beach,
the Turks used their [inaudible],
their knowledge, their experience.
Held their fire until
the British were ashore,
and poured fire into those men.
From Guezi Baba over here, Hill 141,
and from the line of
the Turkish trenches.
The same is true here at W Beach.
Limestone outcrops.
This is a line of dunes here.
We can see here the narrow beach.
All of this had barbed wiring.
All of these trench lines that
followed this concave area.
All picked out, of course, on
the reconnaissance surveys.
And we can see the most
effective kill zone.
As the men were struggling
through the barbed wire here,
they were facing an onslaught
of fire to try and get ashore
and move and move on its way.
And you can see now, can't you,
why it was and why it still is
that Gallipoli is studied
by the US Marine Corps
in considering amphibious landing,
and why this had an element
on the doctrine of D-Day.
Okay, so let's shift
away from Helles.
Yes, the map failed a bit there.
Let's look at the Anzac territory.
Badlands, okay, a bit like
South Dakota or Arizona,
places I've had the honor to
visit in your beautiful country.
And what we can see here
is the incredible element
of the landscape here.
This tortuous land --
doesn't look anything
like Grover's survey of 1876.
What was the plan here?
Difficult to see, I'm afraid,
but what we can see here is this is
Sari Bair, the range of the hill,
which is badland topography.
Another from Gaba Tepe
to the narrows is a
transport corridor, a valley.
The Turks knew that.
They fortified that.
They created a kill
zone of field artillery.
They defended that
as far as they could.
So, there was no way that
the Allies could lend there.
Instead, the Anzacs would land --
Remember, they were
the untrained guys
who felt could be able
to combat the terrain.
Very few Turks here,
relatively unopposed landing.
Very much more combined with the
terrain, a difficult challenge
for the men to get up into
that challenging environment.
So the idea was that they would
rise up, go on one of these ridges,
hit the top of that hill,
rise over the top, get down
and help the other
guys who had landed
at Helles and take the narrows.
Okay, so let's look at
one of the mythologies.
You speak to any Australian.
They'll tell you how the
British generals failed them.
They'll tell you how they
landed in the wrong place.
How the British generals
had no idea.
Part of the enduring mythology
of the Australian male
at the current moment.
So, is there any truth
in that [inaudible]?
The first, second, and third ridges
-- one here, one there, one there.
These are going to be important.
General Hamilton, literary man,
a man who swept his arm and said,
"Right, we will take this area."
He is saying, "Let's go
from Gaba Tepe to Suvla Bay.
So he's saying, "Look, chaps, if you
land here can you take the ridge,
everything will be fine."
General Braithwaite, his chief of
staff, a bit more constraining.
"Hold on a minute, Hamilton.
Our men need some very small
specific landing locations."
Again, the doctrine of
amphibious landings is you have
to plan and plan again.
Now Braithwaite is saying,
"Let's say north of Gaba Tepe,
which is heavily defended,
to the Fisherman's Hut."
Remember Grover's survey?
That area of the Gaba
Tepe to Fisherman's Hut.
The Admiral, Admiral Thursby,
on the 10th of April is
saying, "Hold on a minute.
Let's reduce that a bit."
Now, I know it's the same in
the US as it is in Britain.
The Navy doesn't speak to the Army,
the Army doesn't speak to the Navy,
and the Marine Corps in the middle.
It's exactly the same
situation happening here.
So what we're seeing here is that
Thursby is altering the plan.
He's saying, "Well, let's reduce
the scale of it a little bit,"
whereas Braithwaite is saying
somewhere between that.
And Thursby, on the
night of the landings,
is saying, "I'll tell you what.
We'll reduce it even further."
So all of these messages are mixed,
and nobody is really
getting that message.
So it means that when
the Anzacs finally land,
we struggle ashore here in
yet another concave
location, largely unopposed.
They then have to fight
their way up the ridges.
And it's that which is the butt of
contention, because some historians
or popular writers are
saying that the map failed.
The British land them
in the wrong place.
Not only did the British
land them in the place
which had been long held, the
map accuracy had very little
to do with the landing place.
So we can't blame the map.
This look in more detail at the map.
Let's look at those ridges.
Okay, there's our French map.
You can see beautifully detailed.
Is it accurate?
Well, that's another question.
There's our first ridge, second
ridge, and third ridge going
up [inaudible] to the
ridge top at the Sari Bair.
The British map in this case, not
massively different to be honest.
Just a little bit less
detail, but again, first ridge,
second ridge, third ridge.
And those ridges feature in
all the British landing plans
because Australians and New
Zealanders would fight their way
up these ridges to get to the top.
Okay, they land here,
get up that ridge.
If they land here, get up
this one, and this one.
But the problem is that
the maps that the British
and the French had didn't pick
out what the Ottoman maps did
at a scale of 1 to 25,000.
This is what subsequently
has become known
as Anzac Cove, as it is still today.
We see the first ridge
there has a plateau,
now known as Plugges Plateau.
The second ridge also has a plateau.
These plateaus become very
important because as the Anzacs,
who have not fought a battle
before, are rushing up the slope
in darkness, they get
to a bridge top.
What do they do?
They dig in.
Once you've done again, the
battle is, in effect, over,
because you have to, as
Ryan has pointed out again,
get out of those trenches and
fight the enemy eventually.
You can't sit there forever,
not if you've got a very
precarious beachhead.
And then, this is the
bone of contention,
because not only do you have
a plateau on the first ridge,
you have no means of getting
across because that is impassable.
There is the razor's edge.
Believe me, that is the literally
centimeters -- inches wide.
And so, men trying to get across
here stumbling in the darkness.
No chance.
The actual opportunity was lost.
So stuck on those plateau
tops, the Anzacs would stay
on those plateau tops
throughout the whole campaign.
But let's remember, those maps
were not available during the war,
and are in the planning
stage of the war here.
And also, there were no aerial
photographs that could depict that.
So, what I'm saying then,
is that the battle was really
dependent on the mapping and maps.
But it was also dependent
on the planning
that was going into that campaign.
What became known as the
Battle of the Beaches
in April 1915 was the
battle or battles
that lost the Gallipoli campaign.
Because at Helles and at Anzac,
the tenacity of the troops
that were facing them, the failure
of the troops to get on shore,
the loss of speed and the
development of inertia
as they were starting to be held by
the terrain and the Ottomans meant
that the stability of
those situations meant
that the war was effectively lost.
So, at Helles and at Anzac,
we have beach has established,
and those beachheads
would have to be supplied.
They would have to be improved.
They would have to be therefore
mapped in more greater detail.
So we're now looking at
the latter part of 1915,
when on the Western front,
new techniques were starting
to be derived, starting to be
considered in terms of mapping.
They had some sense of being
able to capture the maps.
So, what we have here is the new 1
to 20,000 scale maps based
on Ottoman originals.
There was a maps officer
that was associated
with the Egyptian service,
British Army, name of TE Lawrence.
You might've heard of him
-- Lawrence of Arabia.
He was involved in the
production of maps there.
The British took this
very, very seriously
and created their own series
of 1 to 20,000 scale maps
with artillery squaring,
again as explained by Ryan.
There are also aerial
photographic plans.
We can see the trenches here.
We can see how this has
been built into a mosaic.
Photo rectification is very, very
difficult at this stage in the war,
but these are being used now to
try and match up with each other,
and we can start to see the
production of sketch maps.
We also get the production
of mosaic photographic maps,
which this was done by the
Royal Naval Air Service.
The British, at that time,
had a Naval Air Service
and an Army Air Service, and
they were obviously still
not cooperating.
But anyway, what we're
seeing here is a production
of an aerial photographic map from
this service of the Royal Navy.
And then we get the
production of trench diagrams.
We are now going from the broader
scale down to the minutiae.
We need the largest
possible scale of maps.
And what we have is the production
of so-called trench diagrams,
which are precursors to trench maps.
These trench diagrams are picked
out by aerial photographic survey
and by trench raids and by
prisoner taking, all those things
that again Ryan has helped us
understand, at a scale of 6 inches
to a mile here, which is 1 inch to
29.3 yards, which is interesting.
We can see all of the
various trenches here,
all named after a range of
locations and places in Paris
or wherever it might be, and we
can see the locations of those.
And that gives rise to the kind of
trench mapping that we start to see
at this point in the Western
front as the Allies got serious
about creating trench maps.
In the trench mapping is actually
a nod towards the realization
that you are stuck where you are,
and that every small
point in detail matters.
It doesn't mean they're
going to win you the war.
So, the increased survey effort
were pretty much to no avail.
Trench warfare, from the failure
of the Battle of the Beaches,
became an attritional battle,
just the same as we had
on the Western front.
The inertia had said in.
What Clausewitz called "friction"
had meant that we are no longer
in a position to be
able to take the front.
The frontal assaults, both at Anzac
and at Cape Helles, where thousands
of men were losing their lives,
not necessarily on the beaches
of Gallipoli as the US
comic book pointed out,
but actually in the killing
fields of the peninsula.
And then, there were new landings.
In August at Suvla Bay, a complete
and utter disaster, a waste of time
with the most inexperienced
general you could possibly think of,
simply because that
general was most senior.
The campaign had been lost
in April, not afterwards.
And once in April, we are
looking at the loss of that.
There was nothing else
that could be done.
No amount of surveying could
win the war for the Allies.
So to finish up, did Hamilton
have everything he could?
Well, yes he did.
He had the maps and the plans.
They were the best available.
The maps, the plans
were all that he had.
There were no new surveys.
The Ottoman Turks had
them -- nobody else.
And there was no means
of carrying out a survey.
So yeah, those maps were done
with the best of intentions
and the capability of these working
in a foreign country
with allies perhaps.
What we can say is, that the maps
themselves were not themselves
responsible for failure.
They contributed to it by things
like the missing [inaudible]
or the location of razor's edge.
But he can't blame a
map for the failure.
You have to think and be honest, is
that the campaign is not only doomed
by the geography of this location,
but it was also failed
by its planners.
You can't send 80,000 men to face
50,000 to 60,000 men on the ground.
Normandy, there were three times
as many Allied troops
as they were German.
So this was lost for
the want of resources,
not lost because of a map, and it
was one by its tenacious defenders.
So it's incumbent upon me to just
say that we must remember all
of these troops, tenacious
defenders, all of those allies
who fought in this
beautiful landscape.
I'd just like again to thank you
very much for inviting me here.
Great honor for me.
Great pleasure to talk to you.
And I'd like to thank Ryan and
everybody else, the directors here,
and the Phillips society for
this great honor bestowed on me.
And thank you very
much for listening.
[ Applause ]
>> Richard Pflederer: I'd
like to thank you, Peter.
This is a very high-energy talk.
Thank you very much.
We have some lights
please, and we're going
to have a few minutes for Q&A.
So let's get Ryan up here please.
And I'll tell you what.
I'm going to stand down here so I
can be out of the killing field.
[ Laughter ]
>> Professor Doyle, a
few quick questions.
Mapping elsewhere in the Ottoman
Empire, for the other options,
for example, Kitchener was
looking at the [inaudible] option.
Was there mapping to
support planning there?
And secondly, at your
conclusion, do you think really,
even if given very good maps
and all the other things,
there was really anything
they could have done
in 1915 to defeat the Ottoman?
>> Peter Doyle: Two very
interesting questions.
The first one --
>> Richard Pflederer: Excuse me,
[inaudible] behind the microphone.
>> Peter Doyle: Oh,
bigger pardon, yes.
The first one, I think
very interesting.
Bear in mind, of course,
that the British were mapping
in these locations.
I'm an expert in this.
I must draw my colleague
into Dr. Peter [Inaudible]
who has worked on this.
But I can say that, for example,
Lawrence had been carrying
out a whole range of
different mapping aspects,
part of his archaeological
investigations,
a lot of it clandestine
to try and do mapping.
There was a lot of work, of course,
in that area because
of the Egyptian survey.
That was very well
furnished with maps.
How well, I couldn't comment on,
but certainly there was
a huge British effort,
bearing in mind the
British involvement
in that part of the world.
The second question -- this
is one of those what if's.
If you're looking for a "what
if" in the First World War,
then the big one is, what if the
Allies had got through in Gallipoli?
The critical thing here is
could the Navy have got through?
Well, potentially.
The Navy could only have got through
if the minefields have been cleared.
Could the minefields
have been cleared?
Well, you need to take Gallipoli.
Could you have taken Gallipoli?
Well, you could have done if
you of had more men, okay,
and if you of had more
resources, better planning,
more opportunity to do that.
Because once those men
are punched through,
you're driving the Turks back.
Suvla Bay, when they landed at
Suvla Bay there were no Ottomans
to speak of in their way.
They could have driven
those men back.
With the maps have helped?
Well, maps are always going to help.
But bear in mind as soon as
a map is made, it's obsolete,
it's out of date immediately.
So you can't blame a map.
This is a man who is
scapegoating this map, is Hamilton.
And I would say there's a chance.
No modern historian would
argue there was a chance.
Everybody would say it
was doomed to failure.
But I don't know -- I'm
a bit of an optimist.
Maybe, just maybe, if we had had
what we know now, if it had learned
from the Gallipoli campaign
through Normandy and Inchon,
all the rest of it, and
come back to Gallipoli,
maybe we would've taken it.
[ Laughter ]
>> Richard Pflederer: A
lot of good questions.
Thank you very much for the
questions and the answers.
Other questions?
Yes ma'am?
>> This is out of curiosity, not
just for myself but for other people
who might not be into war
history and know a lot about that.
Could you talk about exactly
what you mean by failure?
Because in my mind, there's
failure of the whole campaign,
but there's also different levels,
of loss of life or equipment.
And exactly how do
you define failure?
>> Richard Pflederer:
Who is that addressed to?
>> Peter Doyle.
>> Richard Pflederer:
The question is --
everybody else didn't hear it --
how would you define
failure of this operation?
>> Peter Doyle: Well, it
depends who's speaking,
because from the Ottomans,
this is not a failure.
This is a success.
This is celebrated as a great
victory over the Western powers.
Coming to your actual point, if we
step aside from Gallipoli a moment,
an argument last year in the
United Kingdom is, was the Battle
of the Somme a success or a failure?
And in the Battle of the Somme,
as you may or may not know,
there were 40,000 men
killed on the first day
of that battle -- 40,000 men.
So, what we're considering here
is how do you measure success
and how do you measure failure.
And in today's military atmosphere,
the loss of 10 men would be seen
as a massive failure in many ways.
We're looking at what become
acceptable losses to these officers.
Now, in the Gallipoli campaign,
we break it down a little bit.
The maps failed --
that's the argument --
because it didn't provide the
information for the planners to go
on and win that campaign.
I'm arguing, well, that's
a scapegoating of the maps.
The campaign failed from the British
and French and Anzac perspective
because it didn't deliver
the objectives,
which is to knock the
Ottoman Empire out of the war.
But lying on those beaches
and in those hills were
thousands upon thousands of men,
not only from the British,
Australians, and New Zealanders,
etc. Also from the Ottoman Empire,
who lost incredible numbers
of men at that point.
So on that basis, could you
ever say that a battle that lost
that many men was a success?
Possibly not, and maybe I can
bring Ryan into that in relation
to the last battle of the war, where
we see the Americans engaged here.
Is that a success?
Did that fail?
Why was there a commission
to discuss
that where the general involved
was actually exonerated?
And Hamilton also was exonerated,
but shunned into the environment.
So I think we have to be careful
putting a 21st century perspective
on it.
It failed because they didn't
achieve their objectives.
It failed because the maps didn't
possibly do what they wanted to do.
And in terms of a human tragedy, it
was a complete failure, I would say.
>> Further to that, had those
losses been as great as they were
in the objective achieved, it
would've been an expensive victory.
But it is an expensive failure
because the objective
was not reached
and the troops were
ultimately [inaudible].
>> Peter Doyle: And adding
a sort of a rider to that,
the very fact that the
British and French thought
that they could send ships through
-- obsolete is the word they used,
obsolete ships -- It
dawned on the admirals
that these obsolete ships were
full of non-obsolete sailors,
and it was at that point that
the campaign was really doomed.
>> Richard Pflederer: We've got
time for a couple more questions.
Are there any specifically
aimed at Ryan?
>> Ryan, it wasn't part of your
talk, but when we were in Belgium
in the [Inaudible], one of the
things that came through in terms
of tourism was the
absolute massive loss
and suffering of the Belgian people.
And one of the undercurrents
to that was now
that this was simply
the fortunes of war,
but that Germany was particularly
brutal in what they did in Belgium.
How do you feel about that?
Do you think [inaudible]
accurate, or do you feel
that was a consequence
of the circumstance?
>> Ryan Moore: Okay, so
before I answer how I feel,
I'm required to say
that this is my opinion
and not the Library of Congress.
So, I will venture into
these dangerous waters.
Thank you for the question.
One of the reasons that we see
the Germans being, in fact,
very brutal towards the Belgians
is the von Schlieffen plan required
them to move so quickly
through Belgium
to their final objective,
which was Paris.
The Belgians put up a tough defense.
I mentioned some of the forts that
they had and the money they had.
They could punch above their weight.
They were very angry by being
delayed, and that they felt
that the Belgians should
have just capitulated
and allowed their troops
to go through.
And so, this is one of the
reasons that they started
to exact revenge upon the Belgians.
And they were also looking back
to the Franco-Prussian War,
in which the Belgians had irregular
troops, meaning no uniform,
taking pot shots, sniper
shots at German troops.
German troops before
the invasion were told,
"The Belgians are probably
going to do this again,"
which we understand they did not.
But anytime they would
hear a rifle shot,
they'd say, "Hey, Belgian sniper."
They would round up communities
and have summary executions.
So it was a mix of the
plan and then the mindset
that the German troops
had before going in.
I think that's the best way to
answer it, and it was very brutal,
because war is a brutal thing.
Also when they were starving from
the blockade, which I mentioned,
that "We're not going to
get the Belgians food.
It's going to come to Germany."
>> Richard Pflederer: Good
question, good answer.
This is going to be the
last question right here.
>> Yeah, how crucial was
that knifelike ridge?
Which
>> Richard Pflederer:
On razor's edge?
>> Peter Doyle: The razors
edge was -- How crucial was it?
Well, one of the problems we have
is, as the Anzacs are coming ashore
and the argument goes that they
landed too far to the north.
That means they were
facing that first ridge.
And as the first ridge breaks
down into the knifelike edge,
that means of course that they
can't progress but it's more complex
than that because as the Anzacs
came ashore, not only did they get
up into that Pluggie
Plateau and face the ridge,
they were also swarming up in the
[inaudible] and the [inaudible]
and all the other elements
of the terrain.
So the argument is that that did
have the material effect on it,
but the general argument is that
the terrain creates this inertia,
this friction, that as you are
losing momentum, you're starting
to consider the opportunity
to dig in.
And because these men
were inexperienced,
they started to do that.
And there were also stragglers
-- this is not talked about.
I'm not from the Library of
Congress, so I can say it.
These men straggled back to
the beaches and there was a lot
of concern from the Commander
Birdwood that they were going
to completely lose that command.
And that's where Hamilton
said dig in, dig, dig, dig,
and dig into you get your security.
And that's why the Australians
are called diggers in that way.
>> Richard Pflederer: As a
means of avoiding a retreat.
>> Peter Doyle: Exactly.
As a means of holding
on to what that is.
So the razor's edge did have a role
to play in the terrain had a role
to play, but you can't blame
the razors' edges the only real
significant feature
that caused the failure.
>> Richard Pflederer: I wanted
to remind everyone that all
of us are invited to an open house
in the reading room of G and M. It's
on the basement level, right?
I don't know which
one to get off of.
And it is starting in 10-15 minutes
and it will be going on for an hour,
a chance to see some
displays and a chance
to meet some more of the staff.
I'd like to make a
couple of thank you's.
Was that Ryan's idea?
I like to thank the speakers.
Think of the research that
went into both these talks.
Thank you both very much.
[ Applause ]
And I'd also like to thank the
audience for sticking it out.
I know it's a long afternoon,
and maybe somebody's lunch
hour was impacted by this.
But thanks again, and we'll look
forward to another lecture series
from the Phillips Society
sometime in the late fall.
Thank you again, and
class dismissed.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.